we are all wired to approach pleasure
and avoid pain and that is what has kept
us alive in a world of scarcity and the
fundamental problem now is that we are
not living in that world of scarcity we
live in this world of overwhelming
abundance but our brain chemistry and
our wiring hasn't changed so when you
are basically wired to seek out pleasure
and avoid pain and you live in a world
surrounded by Pleasure Goods infinitely
available at the top of a finger and
you're encouraged to avoid pain at all
costs how could we not get addicted of
course we are and we will and I do think
people are beginning to relate to that
especially as regards smartphones and
things that we're doing online because
people are now observing their own
behavior you know losing time getting
caught up I hope that there is sort of
This Dawning awareness that this is a
universal phenomenon